In this homework you're going to be asked to write a grammar that will allow us
to write a parser for the JSON language.
JSON is a data interchange language for JavaScript that allows JavaScript programs
to pass values back and forth and pass them on to other programs.
What I'm asking you to do is to write this grammar.
You can look at JSON.org to see the definition.
There is a little grammar there on the right-hand side.
It's not quite in the right format that we expect here,
so you're going to have to translate it into the right format.
Then you should be able to parse.
A top level is called a value in JSON.
You should be able to parse that with your grammar.
Here I've given you some examples that you can test out to see if they make sense.
See if you can translate the JSON grammar into our format,
and see how easy that is.